go down take the books
put the books in front of you and read
them read the quran don't be afraid
the question is about whether muslims
are or not good citizens
the constitution defines what a good
citizen is and the preamble
says we the people of the united states
in order to form a more perfect union
to establish justice ensure domestic
tranquility
to be muslim i can say that as a good
muslim and most muslims can say that
most muslims will embrace that most
muslims are good
no americans you can take my daughter to
dinner you and my daughter and me
let me tell you something it's natural
that's the idea
god created it and he created us to have
a good time
we should have a good time only with our
wives though
islam is the fastest growing religion in
the world and most of the converts are
women not men
they see that the rules of islam instead
of
constraining them the rules set them
free
okay you've got your dream home and
you've got your dream car but you're
gonna get old and things are going to
happen to you in your life
and then what have you got at the end of
the day it's an empty dream that has
no real foundation we are going to die
and we're going to meet our lord and he
is going to judge us
it becomes an obligation for each single
human being to find out
what the quran is islam is telling us to
stay away from things which are bad for
your person and bad for the society
of innocent human beings human life
is precious
there'll always be someone that'll be
there to say something negative but at
the same time there'll be someone there
to say something positive also
just hold on to the rope of allah
everything in this universe
the quran says don't kill women don't
kill children don't kill the old people
don't attack the civilians this is what
the prophet muhammad told us
and if we're going to worship something
i figured i might as well worship the
creator
instead of any of the creations now
upon investigating all the religions i
remember finding out the meaning of what
islam is what a muslim is
those who surrender their self to god is
a muslim
those who surrender submit to god god's
will
that is it islam was pure it was just
you just pray to god
on the outside everything looks good you
see the hundred thousand dollar cause
you see a lot of diamonds you see a lot
of females and they think that this is
you know this is the life this is this
is
like you know paradise right here on
earth
it's not anyone's job to go into
someone's heart and change their heart
your job is to tell people what the
truth is the reality of it is
while we're sitting here i'm sitting
here constantly paying for the disease
the cure was free
with good deeds uh we'll find that good
breeds
good clear out
of your mind in your heart of hatred
and preconceived notions racism and
nationalism
because you cannot have anything inside
of you
that's like that against people and
still be successful
i know why i did that maybe maybe it's
just to break the ice